how's it going everyone it's Warren and
today is a special day because we have
our first look at fan o's and Avengers
end game thanks to this leaked cover of
Empire magazine this is the first time
that we're seeing Thanos and how he'll
appear in avengers' in game besides a
concept art leak or Lego leaked we have
two full trailers for Avengers in game
and a TV spot and Fanus is not shown in
any of them Marvel is definitely trying
to keep us in the dark about Thanos and
what his intentions are now after the
snap and like the concept art that we've
seen Thanos is wearing his full armor on
this cover thanks to some concept art
leaks and some Lego leaks all of which
Stannis is wearing his armor in we know
that he's going to wear his armor a lot
more in Avengers and game than he did in
Avengers infinity war we also see the
Infinity Gauntlet in his left hand and
unlike what we see in the trailers it is
completely intact and not damaged at all
even though the Infinity Gauntlet was
damaged in Avengers infinity war it is
widely believed that Thanos could simply
use the time stone to repair the
Infinity Gauntlet with this Empire
magazine leaked we also get a picture of
Thanos on his farm in Titan 2 as well as
another Empire magazine cover with all
of the original six Avengers on it
nothing is really different about how
the Avengers look on this cover in fact
most of these photos are simply reused
from the promotions for infinity war
everyone looks the same for the most
part Iron Man is still wearing the same
nanotech armor that we saw in Avengers
infinity war Thor looks the same Black
Widow looks the same still has the short
blonde hair
Hawkeye looks the same he doesn't have
the mohawk hair in this photo and that
picture of the Hulk is definitely a
reused promotional photo that they used
for the promotion of Avengers infinity
war however Captain America does look
different he's clean-shaven and he does
have on his scale uniform the actual
release of these empire magazines
worldwide is scheduled for March 21st in
which we could hopefully learn a little
bit more about Avengers in game and
possibly get some new photos from the
movie as well again we have expected
that Thanos is going to wear his armor a
lot more in Avengers end game than he
did an infinity war and the fact that
he's on the cover of empire magazine
with the armor leads us to believe that
even more so let me know what you think
about this leaked photo for Empire
magazine for Avengers endgame where we
see fan OHS for the
very first time what do you think about
the photo and do you think that the
Infinity Gauntlet will be repaired an
Avengers endgame let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
a reminder that I'm still doing my
giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets so you and some friends can go
see Avengers end game and IMAX if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and of
course if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
in game and all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]